you got to get um artificial
intelligence to make you some Beats
all righty that's the thing huh I think
AI can make beats yeah isn't that
happening
they can
it's not good I heard one I think I
heard a fake Timberland beat that wasn't
terrible you don't think you don't think
we're living in The Matrix bro
I've really started to think about that
more recently with some of the [__]
that's been happening yeah because I
always would be like
like when you you see like the birds
Frozen in the air there's like hundreds
of videos of Just birds that just
stopped flying and they're just still in
the air
everybody not flapping no wings they're
just in there they're just paused bro
you need to show me the footage today
hold on Brett let me show you bro
I want to see the footage of that this
[__] is crazy
this [__] is crazy hold on you got the
birds Is that real though like oh my God
hold on look good
Birds
yeah we got more water we grab a water
over there let me see
appreciate you brother
man get the [__] out of here
you're the only one who saw it
right yes
the [__] out of here there's another one
there's [__] Birds floating in the
air man get the [__] out of here that
[__] looks real there's people saying
that it's dimensional glitches I don't
know I don't know what that means I do
some research
I don't know bro they look crazy well
then when you see the like did you see
the government official like saying that
they're like aliens are real aliens and
[__] yeah yeah I've seen that so that
made me even really be like yeah what's
really going on right now you know yeah
I'll be on some other [__] though I
already I already be thinking of some
other [__] going on what do you think is
going on I don't know
I don't know I just feel like she we
ain't the only ones walking around this
[__] like how we think we yeah I
think that's the facts for sure you know
what I'm saying I think they're
preparing us because I mean if you're
Christian if a lot of people walk around
say hey Christian I mean they mention a
lot of different creatures inside of
that book we read so she I mean what did
they wipe out the face of the Earth uh I
don't know
you know so you think it might be some
Demon [__] going on no some like
entities you know you know they speak
about Giants all type of [__] right yeah
for sure all type of uh
non-human beings yeah and should you be
like oh this is like you know some cool
like uh fairy tale [__] you know like
yeah right well some of that [__] might
be for real who knows I mean you know I
stay the [__] out of the way I get my
money if you look at some of the old
school hieroglyphics from like Egypt and
[__] some of the [__] in those
hieroglyphics is like bro they got to
see this [__] so I'm like
you know what I'm saying like there had
to be some [__] going on that like we
were privy to because [__] just
wasn't but I ain't gonna get after
aliens though
I ain't gonna get this aliens though
that right there what's in the
hieroglyphics like the pictures of like
like alien looking [__] that
were like carved into like me I just
feel like that was a different type of
being it might be an alien to you
because you don't understand it but
I guess aliens to us right non-human yes
I mean that's kind of the definition
it's like yeah so you're right you're
right you're right you're right you're
right you're right I was gonna go into
some other [__] you good you guys I
think I like you know [__] all this
UFO like did you see what happened in
Las Vegas
there was this family in Las Vegas that
called the police because they said
there was like three like 10 foot things
in their backyard creatures right right
and what's going on with that
and so the family uh CIA came the police
came the police saw the [__] thing so
there's the cops body cam footage being
like I just saw that [__] take off from
your backyard like am I crazy am I not
the only people who saw this well like
some Jeepers Creeper [__] so like some
like some like a uh like once the police
got there some like whatever craft
popped out of these people's backyards
so the cops were like all talking about
it like we're not crazy we just saw that
right and then for like the next month
the uh there was black trucks that would
just line up on their street for like
and then the family was documenting it
like on Tick Tock and [__] they're like
look there's more big SUVs outside of
our house that have been here all week
so I'm gonna get out of Area 51 which is
in Vegas well it's in Nevada I used to
live there so all right every 15 was wow
you could drive up to like a certain
point and then there's some [__] over
there oh for sure they have um they told
me uh so I lived in Vegas for a few
years and uh you know who Molly Maul is
bald producer used to be on Love and Hip
Hop he's made a lot of big beats yeah I
think so
um so he had he had a security guard
and the security guard was a former
like military decorated guy right like
top-notch security guy he was explaining
to us when he worked because he said he
worked at Area 51 as a contractor
and he said that they had like other
soldiers behind him who had higher
clearance than them
and they like like let's say they
brought him into a room and they're like
hey you got to work on this wall
um but they were being held cat like I
guard the whole time so they wouldn't
walk anywhere else in the area you know
what I'm saying and he said that that
while he was there he saw
like a metal
or like some sort of matter that no
matter what you did to it if you if you
blew it up if you shot it if you bent it
if you tore it apart it always came back
together to the same uh form Muslim
transformation yeah me you know who Pooh
Bear is the writer Pooh Bear he wrote
all Justin Bieber [__] me and Pooh Bear
was just like we were just listening to
this dude one night at Molly Moss crib
high as [__] yeah tripping
what the [__] is going on right
shout out to you I can believe it though
shout out my brother Pooh Bear man I
think I think [__] like that exists hey
man I just think you know they just let
us they that's why I think they're
easing us into some [__] because they
gotta kind of ease Us in now it's like
they just can't just out of nowhere like
oh no yeah um oh who who's on this uh
new album do you have any features or is
it just you or it's just me I like that
it's just me I think I just I mean I
flooded myself with features yeah you
know what I'm saying it's time to just
get a world of me you know build on my
fans and it's important too because this
is your first independent album so it's
like yo I'm gonna stand out on my own
for real exactly I like that that's
where my mom come from when is the uh
project coming out you gotta release
date yet
um not an exact day give me a couple
weeks it's gonna be here it's coming
soon coming real soon how often do you
plan on just dropping now that you're
like uh you know you ain't got the red
tape the yellow tape around you from the
label I mean I say every two months
that's not bad yeah I say every two
months I mean a song or a project
project
but I mean I'm a forever get them
singles and I always feed them every two
months driving a project I like that why
be independent if you ain't gonna do it
the right way
right yo it's crazy when you're at
what's the weirdest did like because you
always hear like
when people are in major labels they get
certain features that try to get pushed
on to them they'll be like hey look we
want to get you in with this person or
hey this song is just it just just put a
verse on it and it's a hit right did
they try to do that with you over there
they didn't
most of my features came from me so they
never were like hey
try this
nah nah most of my well all of my
features came from me just like reaching
out to people people who you [__] with
yeah yeah Daddy me Dirk Allen it's just
like yo hop on this for me
you know who B.o.B is so back in the day
like Atlantic Records had a hard time
popping B.o.B off right which was on
there them not him because he's
extremely talented so at the time Bruno
Mars
was shopping around all these hooks
because no one knew who he was he was
just a writer
and uh what was that first B.o.B song
was it beautiful girls
so that song I go beautiful girl
what's it called nothing on you nothing
on you oh yeah okay nothing on you yeah
yeah yeah so Atlantic was just trying to
get somebody to take the song Lupe
Fiasco cut on it and then didn't like it
so it should have been Lupe's song he
passed on it why he let me do that I
don't know
Chicago goat by the way man Lupe tweaked
one of the greatest rappers of all time
for some of the straight lyrics
uh and then Bob ended up with it
I was gonna say no I'll just see it but
yeah
I [__] with Bob he used to be hot when I
was young for sure I don't know what up
at the OG's in Chicago tapping in with
you like a Lupe type of dude or yeah
obviously yays the goat you know uh yay
I mean that's happened with yay camp
um
definitely tapped in with a lot of the
other
uh local Legends Crucial Conflict
individuals like that LEP uh bump
s Jay yeah what about [__] uh Do or
Die
um I ain't chopped it up would you
listen to do or die growing up yeah yeah
I still listen to do that to this day I
might be cleaning up the house or
something I'm in Crucial Conflict slept
on [__] groups ever facts that
first Crucial Conflict down which you
probably weren't alive for it's called
the final tick right oh my god when they
come out what year I think that was 95
or six yeah I wasn't even born yet it
might have been 96. they had a song
called hey yeah yeah I want to show them
yeah I was probably I was like 10.
okay you weren't born yet though
but yeah Do or Die po pimping man what
are we talking about have you two you
know Twisters out there doing gun
classes
yeah he's like teaching people like how
to responsibly own weapons in Chicago to
protect himself so you take people and
they'll do classes like how to shoot out
of them how to get your license
actually my my OG went to school with
twister at West oh wow yeah it was the
same High School
slow that [__] down
[__] the whole career later
100 I just a lot of them all right well
look man a new project on the way yeah
Unchained Unchained congrats on your
Independence
uh we just also dropped the freestyle so
you go check that out separate YouTube
video yeah for sure appreciate you
pulling up man and I look forward to uh
to hearing the album
boom